the staycation had stayed cool
long enough in this the year of
postcards home
from home it's a pretty picture
as the temperature soared a population
surged
to the sunspot it was busy in brighton
same for the seaside around the country
this was port call in south wales where
hundreds
reclaimed their place in the sun
it was a return on mass and on notice
beachgoers were reminded to stay
socially distant
to let themselves go without letting us
all go
for me personally it's just nice to
bring this kids out you know as
grown-ups you can you know you can stay
inside but for the kids they want to be
outside in sunshine
so it's been nice to be out as a family
we really really needed it just to pick
people up you know some people get
down depressed or whatever but um it's
just really
just lifting me up anyway it's nice to
be free like i mean um
it's nice to ever see all day everywhere
yeah being obviously welsh weather
it's brilliant of you mate it's
absolutely brilliant
for many sun up is a change up
in gear unlock moment the water skis
were out
as overdue attractions overcome a bad
year
and most recently bad weather
the good weather typically signals the
great british garden center roof
as good as the sun is for a business
like this
covert casts a shadow still
garden centers are reporting a shortage
of garden furniture
brexit is slowing its importation from
the far east
but its availability is also being
squeezed by the way that covert is
making us behave
more and more people are swapping a seat
in the power restaurant
for a seat in the garden
it is a home entertainment system
brought to you
by kobe the furniture sets we've been
selling have been larger not bistro sets
for two sets for
eight people sofa sets that can kind of
seat a family
if they were entertaining and that has
definitely been the case
more so this year than it has previously
inevitably there were traffic jams as
the population
engaged full bank holiday mode but
generally wherever you looked around the
country
it was a lazy hazy day that felt
something like the heats of summer
and it's forecast to get even hotter
james matthews sky news lachlan